according to recent studies 65% that's a
big number
65% of our conversations are consumed of
stories and gossip 65% stories and
gossip did you hear about what Bobby's
going through you heard about what she's
working out do you know what they went
through you know they get in a rut I
think they're like hey did you hey let
me tell you still go what happened
earlier today everything's about story
but sometimes in a world of business we
become so logical because it's number
number number number hidden getting
deadlines deadlines then you forget that
so many challenges in our personal life
business so many of them can be handled
by stories but sometimes people forgot
how to tell stories today we're gonna
talk about the art of storytelling all
right so let's get right into listen we
love stories we love great stores you
and I go to movies we read books because
we love stories now when you think about
history you think about great
storytellers you think about Shakespeare
Homer Martin Luther King Lincoln Eminem
Churchill Clinton Disney Reagan Tupac
biggie it was all a dream
I used to read Word Up Magazine salt and
pepper and Heavy D up in the limousine
you're visualizing it it was all a dream
I used to read Word Up Magazine salt and
pepper and Heavy D up in the limousine
that's a that's a story you're reading
right when when Eminem's telling the
story about Stan when Bill Clinton is
debating George Bush Senior and somebody
in the audience says hey President Bush
how was the debt affect your family how
are you personally affected by it and he
says you don't think I'm affected by you
don't think just because I'm a president
I'm not affected by and a Bill Clinton
comes and says tell me about your life
tell me about your war going through let
me tell you about the story what we did
in the state of Arkansas I remember one
time I remember one time oh my gosh I
want to vote this doesn't mean he's a
better president doesn't mean he's
smarter than George Bush senior's it
just means he's better at telling
stories and in that situation he won
that debate because he told a story so
many times we can win and we can
persuade and we can get our point across
if we simply tell a story so let's get
right into it now five types of
storyteller it's very simple dosoo
persuade okay it could be in a lot of
different places those who inspire those
who inspire
pastors coaches or leaders somebody you
watch motivational speakers who inspire
those who launch revolutions and
movements some positives
negative those who tap into your inner
potential you know how somebody you talk
to and you sit across from them you
almost feel like they just went into
your spirit and they swim and they shock
you and all of a sudden like man I feel
like I can take over the world they tap
into that inner you you know you know
what I'm you've experienced that before
to know what I'm talking about
those to manipulate and these are con
artists you but these are all
storytellers I'm not giving you just a
good or you know all storytellers are
perfect but these are five ways people
tell stories now the part of our
storytelling that's changed the game is
obviously in 1450 things changed when it
was printing press because before we
would just talk a lot and it was all
about conversations then we started
telling stories through writing
obviously the printing press made it
what we can do mass distribution of
storytelling then came you know the the
camera so now a motion picture camera
and then TV came in 1925 and now we
watch TV and then radio and today it's
social media blog it's so in the bottle
if you look at anybody on social media
that's winning if you look at anybody in
Hollywood that's winning if you look at
anybody that's a writer that's winning
you will find somebody that's a great
story too if you look at anybody in
politics that ends up winning I promise
you'll find somebody that's better at
telling stories and other people are
storytelling right now elements of a
great storyteller elements of a great
story storyteller
I got a few points here up here for you
number one they create anticipation like
you're like oh my gosh what's about to
happen here look I want to watch
Hamilton right and I'm sitting like
what's about to happen I'm like this guy
if you ever see the guy that produced
the whole a Hamilton show he's brilliant
the way he gets so excited my second
anticipation I want to see what happens
here there's a certain level of
anticipation of a great storyteller
building curiosity surprise you know hey
let me tell you about the story son said
it was this one guy and he goes in and
as he's going through this place and the
forest and all of us in here the noise
but he didn't know what the noise was so
he kind of backed up a little because he
was afraid then he came and he looked
and he was alone he didn't know what to
do but he felt curious so he went there
and then all of a sudden but it's like
that's the surprise part like just like
you're telling stories to your kids
sometimes right details the key is
details here's where I was at this is
what the place looked like like I was
telling a story earlier when I was
talking
but I'm sitting in a car many many years
ago situation where my sister is sitting
on the front right and my dad's in the
driver's seat and we're in front of
video twenty20 okay in Glendale off of
Glendale there's an IHOP over here
International House of Pancakes there's
a church over there right across the
street was Virgil's and this is Glendale
and uh Doran Street and we're in the car
it's pouring it's absolutely pouring and
my sister and my dad are having to come
in the back seat my sister my dad are
having a conversation my dad says you
know I'll help you get a car and mazda6
too and I'm just going through this hole
I like by the way let me tell you how
old I was I was 15 years old 14 years
old 25 years ago but I remember the
details right because stories are about
the details and a lot of times when
you're telling this story sometimes
people tell way too many details but you
got to tell me enough story while I'm
not there with you I'm like oh my gosh I
know exactly what is that great
storytellers know how to get the details
out to Evan flow of your speech the
volume like no one want to go up one to
come down you know sometimes people are
trying to perfect this too much and
you'll see when it's an axis you just
kind of kind of do it naturally but
eventually you'll kind of know timing
wise what places to take up and down
involvement if I'm somebody that's
listening to you tell a great story
great storytellers typically get me
engaged I'm in there I'm involved in
like yeah I understand I know what
you're talking about I'm involved with
your great story like if I hear a great
storyteller and I'll sit there and I'll
catch myself um again yeah ha that's
right I'm involved I'm engaged on inner
because it's a reflection of a great
storyteller that's gotten my attention
of my involvement within the story
energy energy is very infectious
especially when somebody tells a story
and and sometimes energy people think
you have to be hyping all this other
stuff there are very powerful
storytellers where you feel their energy
but they're not here Clinton's energy is
a different energy but it's high energy
right Obama's energy is a high energy in
his own way some people tell stories in
different ways but they have a certain
energy that you feel timing no one want
to drop this fact and one drop to this
one want to do this there's a lot of
timing things when you're telling
stories number eight is painting a
picture imagination visualization
imagine what you think about this which
or visualize I don't think about one day
what if
that these these words that are used
that tap into our imagination nine show
feelings
I remember Mari and I were having a
conversation together today and I told
him I said you know I don't like to cry
when I give a speech I get very upset on
myself when I when I cry when I give a
speech because for me it's almost like
using it as a tactic and I've spoken I
don't know how many thousands of times
because I speak regularly to audiences
right and I can say I've cried five
times five times I don't tell them story
I said three out of five times I cried
was because of one person in my life and
I was telling about this person that I'm
going back for it but I said but but
when I think about this person it
produces a certain feeling for me that I
go there and when I feel it the audience
feels it because you will know when
somebody goes and taps into a certain
feeling everybody else feel so but you
gotta be able to use your feelings you
know if in that moment you were upset
show me that you were upset if in that
moment you were joy show me you were if
in that moment you were angry if you
were curious if you were afraid if you
were insecure if you were show it to me
I want to feel it I want to know that
what you're telling me I can feel it as
well you can't act that part I want to
know about it you got to show the
feelings when you're telling that
number-10 body language your body
languages you know hand movement and
eventually this becomes natural but body
language bodies move in and in the 11s
climax very similar to many other
aspects of our lives or there's a climax
of oh my gosh that was amazing the end
of the story's got to have a climax oh
my gosh what a story are you kidding me
what a story and by the way here's a key
of a great story a great story is one
that's retold a great story is one
that's retold here's what happens you
hear a story and you're gonna say babe
did you hear about let me tell you what
I heard today oh my gosh let me tell you
the story it's on did you know that
Elton John's been sober for 28 years and
the guy that wrote the music for him was
his best friend and never gave up on and
while everybody gave up on him did you
know this babe that's crazy I can't even
believe it the best stories in the world
are the stories that are rito-san i
watch
this year simple Pat are you trying to
teach me how to tell a story time on my
story two components here to this
episode number one teaching you how to
tell stories by the way you know how to
tell stories so it's not like you don't
know how to tell so since we're being
kids we love stories you love stories
you know how to tell stories we've been
telling stories where we became too
logical you got to get back and tap into
that childlike side of yours start
telling stories again like you always
did here's why
one story telling to your story listen
in life there's a lot of things that you
own that's you you that's you that's
your identity your this is all you
there's a lot of things that people own
we own cars beyond all these other
things we live in a house we sell it to
somebody as we you know own a car we
sell it to somebody else but there's a
few things that's yours one your
signature you sign it's your signature s
why it's got so much value when you go
sir president's signature Lincoln you
can buy for twenty five thousand dollars
when you roll a letter to his wife this
is signature of Al Capone when he wrote
the IRS pop up about forty thousand
dollars this is a signature it's an
autograph of Babe Ruth autograph of
Mickey Mantle look at this over here
because it's so valuable it's yours
signature it's yours you can do what
your eyes closed you don't have to open
it's your signature right this
fingerprint ready fingerprint you know
what the other one is your story your
story it's the best thing it's your
story you own it
it's your fingerprint it's your
signature your story and the way you
live your life that's a story that's
told everything I'm telling you is how
to tell stories but on all this stuff I
hope you realize like I can teach you
this stuff with my eyes closed because I
am enamored by people's stories I used
to run a store my first business I ever
started was called the story builders I
have an email till today that has to do
with the story builders because that's a
business I started many years ago
I mean stories absolutely moved me and
more people tell me why do you like
people so much I love people if I sit
next you on a plane I guarantee you're
gonna be speaking 80 percent of the time
I'm gonna be asking questions I love so
I can't help myself I sit if somebody's
interviewing me within the middle of an
interview I sometimes catch myself
interviewing the other person because I
love stories I am fascinated by your
story and fastener about people's
stories but you need to be fascinated by
your own story you need to go out there
make sure the world knows about your
story because there's only one of you
only one it's pretty emotional I though
if you really get deep and think about
it's only one of you you got to make
sure your story makes an impact so now
last but not least when stories are
effective moments of tension when
there's a lot of chalica day we had a
very difficult board meeting in the
middle of a board meeting it was a very
tough moment last night very very tough
dinner that we had and it was a very
tough moment of tension and I brought up
something and I told the story and we
went through it it was like okay you
know it's pretty interesting and today
is another story you know here's one
okay fine okay we can get through this
no promise what I expect this what I
want to see okay we can work around this
but it was due to a story being told
it's like okay this is safe it's safe
moments of tension tell a story when
nothing and go nothing else works tell a
story validating your point when selling
racing kids tell story tell my kids
stories all the time the other night
it's telling my kids I pulled him aside
I said guys I want to pray tonight
and I need you to pray with me and my
seven of my five-year-old cuz daddies
everything okay I said yes I got to pray
for somebody so I get on my knees and I
start praying and I said look there's
that God somebody my life is really
struggling and they're going through
tough times and I'm having a tough time
with this and I don't know how to handle
this and and and I need your help and I
really want you to empower this person
to realize the life is bigger than this
and I hope they find their demons and
all these things that they're going
through right and I ask my kids he did
wonder you guys want to pray my five
year old Dylan such miss such a he says
daddy I want to say something I said
what do you want to say daddy he says
dear God I want to pray that my dad's
friend who are struggling with I'm not
gonna say the word to staying and and I
am hoping God that one day he can find
this and that that that's so one day he
wants to be like exercise etc and I'm
just sitting next to the skin like
flippin kid man you know he got my heart
immediately but was the moral the story
we sat down with telling stories all
night that night and these kids every
time I tell him stories when something
pops up if I talked about drugs alcohol
you know marriage relationship exercise
friendship bully and toughness respect
if it's always a story-based and they
are
remember the story and they retell it
and they tell it to me they tell its mom
they tell it to their grandpa they tell
it to their nanny they tell it to their
sister they tell it to their friends
they tell it to their teacher and it
always comes back stories when raising
kids coaching leadership development all
of this stuff is around storytelling so
purpose in this video two sides one
you're learning how to tell stories to
you making sure your signature your
story your fingerprint makes a big
impact in this world having said that if
you want to learn more about this kind
of a topic have another video I want you
to watch ok what's the title of the
video it's how to become a great public
speaker I think as a toddler video
here's a thumbnail it's titled how to
become a how to be a great public
speaker and in this video I talk about
different styles that public speakers
take to deliver their message this is
very similar to what I just talked about
so if you want to go back and look
through this again do so and then if
you're done with this go watch the other
video how to be a great public speaker
if you haven't subscribed subscribe to
the channel and if you got any thoughts
comment below thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye